I came up with this this concept it's
almost identical to the final shot oh
my gosh
what are seven fleet's top five tips for
getting good looking energy blasts on
screen
thanks to epidemic sound for sponsoring
this video stick around to the end to
see how you can get 50 off an annual
subscription plan
hey welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artists react we are
honored to be joining the couch once
again by Stephen Fleet the visual
effects supervisor of the boys loss of
you have probably seen it is in my
opinion the best show currently is
airing Stephen thanks for joining us man
thank you uh for having me and thank you
for all the Red Bull dude we got so much
and this is gonna be super high because
of it I think the last time I had a Red
Bull I was doing the reboot of Knight
Rider uh in 2008 really yeah I remember
I had like six in a row and I remember I
was on set and all of a sudden just at
this moment where I was like oh and then
I just like went down on one knee and
everyone's like you okay I'm like just
give me a minute give me a minute I'm
like all right let's go hold up hold up
I'm just trying not to die yeah so maybe
maybe not six in a row but one one is
good did you know your heart can beat in
triplets
uh don't try that at home
all right let's uh let's do this thing
man Sweet let's just jump around
oh look at the little hamster so in this
there's Jamie the hamsteros Russian for
Jamie right there so in this instance we
did shoot a real hamster but it was a
very controlled second unit shoe what
you're seeing when you're seeing the
hamster yeah it is it is real
my daughter one two three
and then you get into CG uins
there you go so now he's flying up and
again we went shallow depth of field to
help take the curse off the CG and then
he just moves fast and then yeah a lot
of blood a lot of blood in darkness
things I learned there's no way to like
throw a hamster in a scanning Booth
because he's not gonna stay still for
that so you just get a lot of photos and
you like throw rulers up to him and get
as many measurements as much reference
as you can and because we did shoot a
real hamster we had some great lighting
reference what's kind of cool about this
whole sequence from here to like the end
of this show is the previous thing I use
this guy named John who he owns his
company out of Texas called concept we
did a bunch of like Unreal Engine stuff
before we shot them and it's crazy how
good it looks and how close it is
this is an interesting one because we
did a lot of r d on post and what his
last would be I really went down the
rabbit hole of researching plasma as
related to nuclear fusion and you need a
lot of hot plasma for it to happen so
there's these cylinder Chambers they've
created with like plasma which is
basically gas but it can look really
interesting and be purple and all
different colors ultimately it came up
with what I think looks like a pretty
cool chess blast but like the journey
the journey was deep man so we knew we
were going to overexpose it I was gonna
mention that I was like I noticed how it
was Overexposed but it felt intentional
it's interesting because instinctually
and this happens a lot on the show a
visual effects artist will turn in
something with just a [__] ton of
beautiful detail but it's not real again
it comes back to what cameras can and
can't shoot you're in a very dark
environment ideally your your exposure
is set to this dark environment so
anything bright is going to clip so you
know you you have to make it real for
this show and I mean real it's a blast
coming in a guy's chest but we were
affected the camera that would clip it
so it became a lot about the edges and
seeing how the different Frills that's
where the plasma stuff actually did come
in in the reference we didn't want to
just go for straight up fire so you know
we tried to add our own little spin on
it and then the chess glow stuff I mean
I've done a lot of it um I did a show
for Marvel back in the day that featured
a glowing fist like like a certain type
of metal yeah it's like an iron with a
fist or something like that I did a lot
of research at that time for like
internal glows and that stuff to me is a
lot about putting um negative space it's
about the light coming through veins and
then it comes down to color too it's
really about like the fall off of like
the white to the yellow to the orange to
the red it can look really pasted on if
you don't get the fall off looking right
what are seven fleet's top five tips for
getting good looking energy blasts on
the screen Planning number one just
planning planning planning planning
planning and practical lighting if
you're in a dark environment like this
for sure and then interestingly enough
like r d in post because no matter how
much you try and prepare make still
images you're never actually really
going to nail it until you have the real
footage that you're working on and then
I would say
um cold brew you're drinking a lot of
coffee and uh is that five yeah four
four [__] uh yeah I don't know man just
like uh doing like millions of versions
so this guy's you know he's got tree
Wayne that's his sort of superpower and
we needed to show it like at least once
just to show that he's more than just
like a gun toning dude
so we're down there and we're scouting
this thing and everyone's talking about
bullets pinging everywhere and I'm like
man I have to like I have to hone this
in like I have to decide what this is or
it's going to be like a big old you know
Smorgasbord in post so I poly scanned
this garage and then I came up with this
whole concept it's almost identical to
the final shot really yeah that's six so
that's why I'm excited about it like it
came out like really tight but it's a
very interesting shot it's multiple
phantom camera 480 frames very difficult
to do in a dark location because the
minute your frames go up your light
shoots up also just real quick the other
thing too this is more of a
cinematography thing but it's
interesting every tube every light up
there had to be replaced by special
lighting or equipment
yeah everything will flicker especially
a good point when you do slow motion you
know your camera is going to capture
more frames per second American lights
have a refresh rate of basically 60
hertz so that's the electricity
switching directions and the alternating
current 60 times a second which leads to
things flickering at either 60 or 120
hertz okay 120 times per second usually
not a big deal when you're recording at
24 frames a second because the flicker
is happening you know more than once for
each frame so you just get normal light
but once you crank up to that slow
motion and now you're running at 500
frames per second you can see the
moments the lights turn off and turn
back on and it looks like garbage yeah
you can have slow-mo shots we got from
Adam Savage's Workshop yep I'm jealous
the one thing that really Drew my eye
was the scrape across butcher's face
there like it actually feels like
there's depth in that scrape and you can
see like the waves echoing through his
cheek there's like there's shape to that
cut you can actually see the highlights
from the lights on the bottom of the
skin like that Ridge that is now there
is brighter than the rest of his skin
and then you have the flip side of that
it's actually darker on the underside of
the top it's just like it feels like
it's deep it's funny how you latch onto
that because ultimately I think we
landed the shot you know after a month
or so working on it and then we probably
spent the last 10 versions of the shot
dialing in that really yeah and um so
what we did is I had them have a
practical makeup scar there on the day
because again even if you're going to
have to erase and replace it which we
did because the angle wasn't quite right
yeah you have something practical
there's reference for lighting right and
it's easier to just paint it out on a
nice flat cheek surface and actually the
most interesting thing is for the
longest time we had these drops of blood
flying with it coming out with it and
they were taking me out of it and they
just weren't working so finally the last
thing was like could we just turn them
off and see what it looks like and that
ended up being the winner we actually
really try and pair stuff down on this
show and quote unquote keep it grounded
deep beneath the quaint Village of
cecilton evil
evily
an infection one that could turn that
host into a fear of Mind fled a being of
immense psychic power
what's the problem faster
you are adventurers you've accumulated
so much knowledge between each one of
you we've been following the source of
this mind player Hive we need to go
deeper I have a bad feeling about this
I was wondering when you would make it
here
in this Hive there are thousands of
years of knowledge
this Hive oh more than live right
someone in that group of yours is hiding
secrets for you to sit here and judge me
and to blame me is very weak of you
that's not how this game works the only
reason that anyone is still standing is
because of us we won't survive unless
we're together
we have to bring your HP to zero this is
the most important dice roll of your
entire life you better do it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome I am Lehman and welcome to my
leisurely lair
we really hope you check out the second
season of our show son of a dungeon a
ton of new Cutting Edge awesome VFX
techniques were used to make this
possible the first two episodes come out
next week on Corridor digital.com check
it out
you heard my brother
I'm gonna get away I when I first read
this scene I felt like it was really
important like for visual effects to
nail this one oh man take it like really
seriously
oh
my gosh
here's the challenges to pulling off
their scene Jesse is a really in-shaped
guy he cannot run as fast as a train in
real life I mean weird okay I keep
trying to get him to do it but he's just
like no man the first couple shots are
sort of the more traditional a train you
just have him run out and sort of
re-time it add smoke this is just a
lock-off plate we had him run in real
time
well to a point I think they stopped
somewhere half when they became dots I'm
like okay guys but yeah no he gets he
gets a workout so like things you do to
a shot like this they were all planned
right shake the camera when he goes by
it throw up the dust and the Pebbles of
the camera and then in post I was like
we should delay the helmet we need to
see them run and then have the helmet
come in even again if it maybe makes no
sense like logically or whatever just
story Wise It's a pacing it's a pacing
thing exactly so that actually was the
button that made the shot the
interesting thing about the two close-up
shots is it's all CG all the blood on
him oh okay yeah okay it's basically a
blue screen of the guy running smacking
down onto blue pasted into these plates
that we've sped up and extend did by the
way just to point out that his suit has
blue and green in it oh
it came to a point where it really
didn't matter
I mean we did a whole
even try to key out we just used the
DaVinci Resolve magic mask and it like
it did it perfectly yeah if you're gonna
go Roto like the exposure behind things
is really important so like if you're
gonna put a dark background behind
people that were lit behind something
that was like lighter they're gonna have
real Edge problems right you gotta know
what's going back there you got to think
in like Angel atoms zone system stop
exposure or like ire meters and all
kinds of stuff that's actually like a
pretty legit Pro tip right there yeah
once zebra stripes came onto some of
cameras like I use a a73 a74 and it's
got that zebra stripe feature I'll just
set it to like 70 which is kind of where
I want like human skin to be and I'll
just make sure that my subject where I
want the key to be is like stripy and
you just kind of let the rest be what it
is man that's the subjects what's
important yeah obviously like you get
into more sophisticated cameras you can
capture more range and then you know you
don't clip out things but at the end of
the day it's all just we're just making
art man just telling the truth just
telling stories
swato is another great like opportunity
for us to bring a little comedy into the
show
he's kind of birthed of this conspiracy
that the the fans had season one and two
we just had all these shots where there
was like a fly in him randomly and
everyone kept saying he was a soup
called swato from the comic books so we
wrote him into this season we played
that up in his wings and like how goofy
is when he runs and like you know the
way they unfold and he's just literally
like [__] [__] [__] and then he's fully
CG so it's a clever kind of like Texas
that's a bit of the Texas switch yeah
yeah so he runs and just like ducks out
of frame and then you come in full CG
and he's flying up there I love how he
pushes a smoke trip yeah and then seeing
his body parts too like pieces and you
know it's comedy like it's horror
horrific but we're playing up comedy
maybe you'd find a man
stood out here playing Captain lesbo
oh yeah look at that so when you're
doing a lot of you know practical
explosions and things like that you show
me how you'd set it up safely that's
cute so if you're going to do a big
explosion the first thing you're gonna
you know discuss is how far away it is
and like what you can and can't have
people around and so in this case we're
going to blow up this Jeep and it's a
pretty substantial big explosion so no
one can be around it so what we
developed uh is a lock-off shot and we
shot it all in plates and put it all
together sort of classic visual effects
but what's cool is it allowed us to have
a real explosion in the shot completely
safe because no one was there when that
explosion went off I planned the crap
out of this I came to set with like a
cell document with images of every
single plate we needed I find that like
the more Visual and clear you can be
with everyone on the day the faster it
goes a couple things lock off shot wider
you can always zoom in a good 20 30 in
this day and age and add handheld and
all that stuff in post don't just put
like the nuke camera Shake Plug-In or
after effects wiggle yeah on it like go
and take an iPhone or something and and
film something and track it or like in
this case I actually put an iPhone on a
shoulder rig I pretended I was on a
shoulder and you know you go track it
and you're like do that like that's
that's what I want so anyway so they're
a plate on blue screen the guy Claudio
that comes out he is squibbed um
traditional uh scribbage he comes out on
a separate plate on his own and he gets
shot up and that's all mostly practical
little visual effects augmentation of
the blood this is a more Misty blood
because it's actually real a lot of it
the two people that fly up in the air
that are sitting on the Jeep they're a
separate plate those are real people
those are real people are just stunt
guys on wires man the comping on is so
nice yeah they're like very nicely like
Edge lit yeah it's like the light wrap
around them is like Flawless yeah so I
just assumed they were CG no so they're
they're they're people that are there
and then the explosion element so it's
this big comp sandwich that we put
together uh it's the technical term for
it you can look it up in the VES
handbook so you get a lot of real things
you got this you get this guy really
reacting to squibbs you get some people
really flying in the air you get a real
explosion you know if anyone's going to
tell me that explosion looks CG I'm
gonna be like I'm sorry because it's
real so when you're shooting these
different plates like where's the focus
set to is any of this Focus faked after
the fact because it's like obviously the
dude is in Focus here and the foreground
is out of focus and even the explosion
in the back is kind of out of focus do
you intentionally shoot this big
explosion this big moment you've been
planning for weeks do you intentionally
shoot that out of focus no no that's a
great question so in an instance like
this I would have them do all of the
focus on the subjects of that plate and
then create the focus in post-production
so even the the front two actors there
in the foreground they're in focus in
the original plate that you've pushed
out of focusing Post Yeah correct that's
going to allow you to create rack
focuses if you want to like we could
have you know react to the explosion in
the background and and made him blurry
we could have we had that choice in
post-production right like you can
really control it if you do that I will
do references though again like I'm all
about the references so what I'll do is
I'll shoot them in focus and then I'll
say Throw go deep and throw focus in the
distance and then I'll see what they
look like out of focus and then I can
show the visual effects company this is
what they look like out of focus nice uh
and so again and we'll get Chrome balls
and gray balls and hdri's even though
technically there's nothing CG about
this shot you're going to get that
information just in case you have to add
a a bullet or yeah you know what I mean
you know one thing in that explosion
shop that sit down it's when she raises
her pistol right at the end when you
have out-of-focus edges it pulls the
exposure down on the stuff behind it and
the fact that the blurry edges of her
pistol there pull the exposure down the
fire and they turn it the correct orange
red that fire does when you expose out
of it that's a really nice touch and it
makes it feel like it's not a comp shot
yeah exactly and you wouldn't have been
able to Roto a blurry pistol and get
that edge necessarily so yeah no what it
what it means is that when they defocus
this instead of just using like a
gaussian blur or something like that
there's great plugins or other types of
blurs out there like uh fish lifts fish
Focus fish moved or Paragon Labs bokeh
one of those two there's there's the
plugins that you know emulate all of
that stuff for real and you know time is
so precious but you can't rush something
like this if you're going to film
something you have to make sure that you
have professionals that know what
they're doing and really take your time
and be responsible if you go on a set
and you don't know what you're doing
you're going to burn a lot of time so
you want to know what you're doing when
you get there I get a lot of like um I'm
gonna supervise something for the first
time what do I do and I'm always like
test test test test test we constantly
the special effects guys will be testing
stuff and sending it to the team and
Eric I'll be testing stuff you know just
test test and then you'll you'll be
happier with the result obviously
there's a lot of Gore in these violent
movies that we love and enjoy we should
look at more of them but I don't know
what to look at leave a comment down
below with your suggestions it helps a
lot thank you hey what's up I'm Nick I'm
usually the guy behind the camera but
today I'm sitting down on the couch to
talk to you guys about epidemic sound
which is today's sponsor it's a One-Stop
shop where you pay a subscription to
access the whole library of royalty free
music Foley sound effects and and we use
it constantly for this show and all of
our other videos and have for years now
so basically with one subscription
you're free to use all of epidemics
library and you're totally legally
covered for online content social media
platforms and websites you don't need to
worry about someone coming after you
years later from legal department saying
hey you used my track in one of your
videos like five years ago I need all
the ad revenue from that it's all
royalty free for you to use there's also
like a ton of options epidemics catalog
has over 35
000 professionally produced tracks and
over 90 000 sound effects and if those
numbers sound a bit overwhelming don't
worry because they have these really
cool search functions that let you
narrow down their whole catalog you can
even search by bpms for that easy mix
that easy transition as someone who
edits another thing I really love about
epidemic is that they give you the
option to download stems for every track
so you know this track right here it's
like all right I just want to cut it to
the drums
get some instruments in there and we're
gonna drop the whole thing now
see that's pretty cool whether it's
sound effects to highlight your VFX or
music to underscore your YouTube videos
epidemic has what you need there's a
link in the description right down here
give it a click and use the code
corridor50 that's Corridor 5-0 it'll get
you 50 off your annual subscription plan
to epidemic all right have a good one
back to the episode Stefan thank you so
much for joining us this has been a
blast I can't wait for season four next
year thank you guys uh for having us and
yeah I guess they did officially
announce that there will be season four
and uh yeah I'm excited for too thank
you guys it's been it's always great
coming here you guys are awesome hell
yeah I really appreciate it and I hope
you enjoy your next nine months in
Toronto thank you yeah winter